my nephew who's a competitive little kid
does not like losing he had the worst
team in the league and he played a game
and they he scored the losing touchdown
um and he was very angry
and my sister didn't dispense to him the
standard parenting advice it doesn't
matter who wins or loses what matters is
how we play the game you know which
raises the question then why do we keep
score because she'd been hearing all my
ideas about the infinite game
spontaneously decided to say okay so you
had a behind day what are you going to
do so make sure you're having a head day
next time and by by telling people that
it's not a good day or a bad day
or we won or we lost because those
things are final and in business
unless you go out of business
you haven't lost anything
but rather it's about a head and behind
because when you're behind it's not
permanent but when you're ahead it's not
permanent
and so it keeps you humble when you're
doing well and it keeps you motivated
when you're when you're falling behind